My glyphosate test came back still very high.
After two years of detox and eating it, organic, does this surprise you at all?
How can I get rid of this?
You know, this is, this is really sad because it's, this is what we were talking about before
was that you could do, eat perfectly and all you eat is organic.
Why would I possibly have glyphosate test hike because the truth is, you could get glyphosates,
you know, through organic food, it's cross-contaminated, you could get glyphosates from, you
know, you know, sprayed, you know, in public places that are sprayed for weeds and things.
So it's, it's so prevalent in our society.
That's why I said it's, there's, this is why the rate of cancer has gone through the
root.
This is why the rate of autoimmune diseases have gone through the root, the rate of chronic
illness has gone through the root because we are being systematically poisoned and, you
know, there is, there isn't like a perfect way to get rid of glyphosates.
So we just continue to work on detox pathways and continue to support detoxification.
Now we're dealing with this forever chemicals that are in everything.
They just, they just tested toilet paper, every toilet paper they tested head forever chemicals
on it.
What are going on?
It's like, it's like they're doing it on purpose or something.
I didn't say that.
I just said it's like they're doing it on purpose or something.
It's insane.
So it gets depressing and you just got to go, no, I'm not going to get down about it.
It's going to keep doing everything I know to do.
That's right.
It leaves it.
It wants to go on.
That's the only way that you can deal with such insanity.